so welcome to Hands-On Network
science let's start with what is a
network uh a network is a set of defined
relationships across items within a said
there are a lot of different networks
that can exist for instance we can have
people connected to each other on social
media we can have Geographic areas
connected by animal Migration patterns
we can even have stocks connected by
buyer Behavior or Goods connected by a
supply chain
and we can even have ideas or parts of
speech connected semantically there are
lots of different networks out there and
most data can be represented as a
network there are a couple important
structures that networks have that are
really interesting for us to analyze and
important to the overall functioning of
the network hubs are densely connected
regions so we can think of groups of
friends who all know each other or all
frequent the same location
we can think of cities that have many
international flights connecting them to
other cities or watering holes where
many animals congregate hubs generally
are very dense and there are regions
where there can be a lot of very quick
spread of ideas or
diseases um or
behaviors Bridges by
contrast may not be densely connected
regions but they're connections between
different regions so an individual May
span many different social groups and
connect those groups together
manufacturers May provide common parts
that are used in a lot of different
Industries to tie together a supply
chain and common food sources might
exist for many types of animals such as
bait balls in the
ocean there are many advantages of using
network science formulations for data
science and machine learning problems
for one network science algorithms tend
to be more computationally feasible than
traditional approaches for instance
let's consider spatial regression for
change Point detection across time and
space a lot of the traditional
regression models have many
autocorrelation components for both the
time series part and the geographical
part this requires a lot of parameter
fitting and large amounts of data to be
able to get a good model and a lot of
computational time to estimate all of
the parameters
however formulating this as a network
science problem allows us to scale a lot
more quickly and because the network can
be distributed we can actually parse
this into parallel Computing
Frameworks the same holds for time
series methods a lot of models require a
lot of assumptions and they require a
lot of parameter fitting and a lot of
data to be able to fit in accurate model
versus Network science methods that can
detect some of these changes within a
Time series very quickly and easily
without a lot of parameter fitting in
addition networks allow for a very nice
visual representation of data and
algorithms as well as what's going on
within the algorithms so when we're
looking step by step at how a network is
changing or
how different structures or spread are
going on with in a network we can
visualize each of these steps as output
to be able to see how things are being
fit over time in addition Network
science shares many deep connections to
mathematics including topology geometry
and dynamic systems theory and this
allows us to leverage a lot of different
tools to understand what's going on in
the network and be able to come up with
new algorithms that we can run for
specific
purposes let's dive into a couple of
case studies and see network science in
action our first case is one of the more
typical uses of network science epidemic
spread so in a lot of communities and
social networks and um other entities
involving people we often want to
predict and stop disease harmful
behaviors or
other things that are going on within
this network to be able to protect the
health of
population and as we can see on the
right there's an example um of a social
network um my own social network uh back
in medical school and we wanted to look
at uh specific tools to be able to
identify spreading behavior on a network
like this so first we collected this
data set which is static it's not
changing over time and it represents
friendships across two different social
groups groups that are just connected by
two individuals and we wanted to look at
disease spread to predict severity
within the network and tests out
different strategies to be able to pre
prevent disease spread within the
network so we looked at first of all
different sir models
which model different parts of the
epidemic you have susceptible
populations that haven't been infected
yet infected populations that have the
disease and recovered populations that
have already had the infection and are
now immune and this model is a system of
differential equations that can be
adapted to the connectivity of the
network so that we can look not just how
it might spread through a population but
how it would spread through a population
with specific relationships in place and
specific hubs and specific Bridges on
the upper right it may be a little bit
hard to see but we can see the epidemic
on the full Network um with one of the
types of epidemics that we wanted to run
there are different parameters that we
can play with within the differential
equations that will control the spread
um across time and across space so this
involves an epidemic that crosses four
different time periods and infects most
of the individuals in the network
however we wanted to look at specific
vertices in our Network that we could
remove um within a real epidemic we
might quarantine the individuals or
vaccinate the individuals to prevent
them from being able to spread a disease
um AC within a hub or across um bridges
that connect different hubs and we used
the tool called for and Richi curvature
which is a geometric measurement of
centrality essentially it measures how
much other vertices are tugging at a
specific vertex um to create a a force
of attraction on it and so we removed
the highest ranked vertex and we found
that we lessen the epidemic by one time
period and there were a lot fewer
individuals being infected this was
about half of the network that was
infected versus the entire network um so
we found this to be one of the more
effective means of
controlling the spread of disease within
a network and in other papers that have
come out um they found very similar
things in different types of epidemics
and different types of behavior spread
um just removing one or two individuals
from a network through vaccination or um
other targeted Public Health
campaigns these epidemics are able to be
stopped pretty
quickly
let's switch gears and look at a
different problem um the problem of
stock market prediction so one of the
big problems within investing is Market
crashes it's very important to
understand when these might be coming
to be able to put economic policies in
place to soften the landing for those
impacted to be able to um adapt trading
behavior and strategies for upcoming
crashes and downturns in the economy so
this is a change Point problem in Time
series analytics however the data is
often not stationary which is an
assumption of a lot of common parametric
time series models and it's also
difficult to model time series data at
scale so if we're looking at Daily data
over decades it can be very difficult to
fit these models computationally so we
decided to look at
a network science way of predicting
these
crashes so we collected NASDAQ data from
2004 to 2020 for four different stocks
Apple alphabet Nvidia and Microsoft and
when we looked at this we see
different periods where there's growth
there's crashes there's acceleration of
growth and these don't always overlap so
we can see here in 2014 and 2015 we have
um Apple kind of making gains while the
others are fairly constant and alphabet
kind of had a downturn in that period
so while some of the behavior is fairly
correlated we we don't see that across
all of this so we wanted to see if we
could predict the volatility of the
stock market Market um using our for and
Richi
curvature so for this we windowed our
time series it's a pretty common
technique within time series to kind of
partition out the series into time
windows and then we created thresholded
correlation networks so we looked at the
correlation across stocks within that
overlapping time window for each of
these windows thresholded them um we
looked at a couple different thresholds
of correlation for what was correlated
and what wasn't correlated to create a
network and then we tested a few
different network science tools to see
which ones were good at predicting
future volatility of the market this
included foran Richie curvature again
betweenus centrality page Rank
centrality and degree centrality to
assess this risk and we found that most
of them do a pretty good job of of
figuring out where the the correlation
is happening and where things are
getting to be more coupled and more
vulnerable to outside effects that might
tip all many stocks at the same time um
and we can see the results on the right
uh the spikes in these different colors
indicate periods where volatility is
increasing and we did find the periods
where we would expect to see this change
including the crash of 20 eight and the
effects of
covid another important problem is
understanding the impacts on food
pricing across different
geographies um there are a lot of local
and Global factors that can influence
local prices of goods and being able to
understand when those prices might spike
is really important for food security So
within this we wanted to look at Millet
prices across markets across the country
of Burkina Faso which in this time
period were impacted by supply chain
problems Global Trends such as covid-19
the war in Ukraine and also local
variations um in rainfall in temperature
um which all have an impact on the local
Supply at markets um one of the cool
things that we can do with this is look
at climate change over time um how local
factors are influencing certain markets
and where food Aid might need to go
within a geographic region so this data
set has spatio temporal aspects um it
has both the spatial component across
different provinces of binaso as well as
temporal effects of collecting this data
over time and spatio temporal model
regression models um have a pretty high
computational cost and require a lot of
assumptions of stationerity which our
data did not meet so we turned to
network science to try to find some of
these change points like we did with the
stock market just within the context of
spatio temporal
data so we had quarterly Millet prices
that were averaged um across each region
the time period was from 2015 to 2022
across 45 administrative provinces um
with market prices for each Province
averaged for that time
period we looked at overlapping time
windows again and instead of using
correlation we used a spatial data
statistic known as the local Moran
statistic which essentially does a
geography based Twist on correlation we
were looking at correlation that was
weighted spatially with provinces that
shared a border and for this we limited
ourselves to looking at pay drank
centrality and for and REE curvature
centrality to assess the risk um we
plotted one of our time periods right
here to see markets where prices were
very correlated as we can see there are
a lot of different um fractions here we
have some that have very high
correlation um that form clusters of
price and geography and we have some
that are fairly isolated and um fairly
weak correlations um which is very
interesting these patterns changed a lot
over time as we can see in the bottom
right um we have Foreman Richie
curvature changing quite a bit over time
um and we do see um as 2020 approached
that the volatility was increasing
within prices um which essentially set
up a that event once covid happened and
some of these Global impacts started um
fortunately the volatility seems to have
leveled out a bit more in um in recent
times which suggests that prices might
stabilize in the
future in conclusion there are a lot of
benefits of network science-based
approaches to data problems including
computational feasibility easy
visualizations and interpretable results
um some of the future
directions where we haven't seen a lot
of work in network science include these
spatio temporal and temporal data
applications there are a few papers out
right now but it hasn't been widely
explored with all of the different types
of data and different types of tools
that can be developed for change Point
detection and um data mining Within
These Frameworks in addition the scaling
of problems is another direction to be
explored especially within um some of
these more novel uses for Network
science there are a lot of different
software packages that can be used
especially igraph Network X and there
are a lot of books out there that can be
used um the one that our team
collaborated on that's been released is
the shape of data um and there are a lot
of tutorials that you can find if you
Google some of these Network science
tools and packages um so whether you're
a python user or an R user you should be
supported and that's the end of our
presentation and we
can skip to questions
now
um do we have any
questions okay I can answer that um it
has to do with uh the formula you can
change the sign and it becomes positive
um but the way that it's measured um
typically we're looking at negative
values because it creates a hyperbolic
space um anything you want to
add yeah I think um is um more or less
what you
said uh so the Q vure um can be negative
depending on
the on the on the shape of the data you
know when you when we in Geometry if you
consider for example a sphere or a plane
or an hyperbolic plane you have a
negative cuure and then when you have um
for example a sphere the which is
positive and the
plane um the K is negative so that's why
we
having uh this yeah I hope this
help yeah um just about every Network
winds up being a hyperbolic geometry
it's very interesting how that works um
I think because there are so many spokes
as opposed to um dense hubs that it just
kind of works out to be
negative
okay so is this we have Dennis who ask
can you talk about can you talk more
about what Tres shoulding means that's
in the
chat that Den sine
in the chat yeah I can get us started on
that um so
thresholding is basically choosing a
cutoff value above which a connection
exists and Below which a connection
doesn't exist there are weighted
networks and unweighted networks um a
lot of times it's advantageous to use
the unweighted networks a lot of the
more complicated mathematics works out
um um a lot nicer um when we are just
working with ones and zeros versus
fractional
values yeah I think I think that that is
enough I think it's okay so
yeah okay it looks like another
question is your book a good place to
start for someone who doesn't have much
experience with network analysis
science yes I I would say so we haven't
assumed any prior knowledge of network
science um the shape of data doesn't
have any um assumptions of that um the
second book that we're working on
focuses solely on network science um and
is a bit more advanced with the
applications but the shape of data keep
things pretty simple with social
networks I think that's okay what s just
mentioned I think it's okay you can
start in that book and there's another
one uh that is still that's still in we
are building on just focus on net
science but if you want uh we can I can
give you some more interesting reference
where you can start from basic Network
science so I can type some links in the
chat yeah some nice reference and can
start from there but I think the book of
s is a good is a nice place where you
can get uh some insight on network
science yeah you know we just had 30
minutes uh not a place to lay out all
the N Science Background thank
you
any other questions well Frank is
looking
for the
references um there are a lot of
tutorials out there with um python in
network X and
igraph uh looks like here is there any
place we can see the notebooks and
examples um yes that's something I can
provide um I don't think we have enough
time to go through all of the code for
them um but if you want to
connect um on LinkedIn I can send you
the notebooks and the data for each of
these um the first example you can find
on the shape of data website with no
search press um that's all open source
code and the others
are from our forthcoming
book so um that is my contact if you
want the notebooks that um are not out
there yet um I can send those to
you
so any other question I think I just
sent a link on the book uh and title I
think
structure of complex
Network Fey and applications yeah that
one I think is important yeah it starts
from basic
stuff uh to more advanced St so have
Theory and application so it can give
you idea and yeah as
mentioned uh I think a good way to start
when you want to code is Python and you
can look at igraph and network X I think
they on the slide and then they are very
nice tutorial and also in the book of
SAR F on the shape of data you have also
very nice scod
it's